si je peux parce que vous n'avez pas
répondu mais peut-être que vous l'avez
oublié moi j'ai évoqué les
avec le dérèglement climatique les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre comme
la fonte du pergélisol qui dégage du
méthane avec le fait aussi que les
océans et avec les feux de forêt on va
avoir moins d'absorption du dioxyde de
carbone donc là comment on comptabilise
tout ça parce que ça pour le coup ça va
évidemment interférer avec toutes les
bonnes résolutions toutes les actions
qu'on va pouvoir mettre en place pour
diminuer diminuer les gaz à effet de
serre parce que pour le coup ça va
augmenter les gaz à effet de serre 100
kg et d'activités humaines directement
liés même si c'est dû finalement aux
conséquences de l'activité humaine passe
vous avez raison madame la sénatrice est
un sujet majeur
le pergélisol ou permafrost or conclut
souffrent plus souvent le nom français
est un est un sujet de préoccupation
considérable la russie on est on est
couverte et
si
la température continue à augmenter il y
aura des fuites de méthane absolument
considérable c'est pourquoi il d'abord
il est très important de d'être en
mesure de les identifier
et ça on commence à voir les outils pour
ça avec des images satellitaires dans le
monde entier qui permettent comme je le
disais il ya un instant de de
cartographier des émissions comme
celle-là la science et vient à notre
rescousse certaine façon puisque nous
avons nous avons beaucoup de moyens de
de quantifier tout cela
mais vous avez raison ça contribue ce
que vous dites nous nous incite encore
davantage à faire tous les efforts
nécessaires pour rester le plus près
possible de 5 degrés est ils n'ont pas
ou monter le rapport du giec de 2018 à
cet égard étaient éloquents puisque
c'était le rapport du giec sur les amas
de graisse 5 il disait que chaque
dixième de degré supplémentaire
engendrait des conséquences bien plus
considérables et presque exponentielle
donc nous n'avons pas de temps à perdre
[Musique]